how's compresses beautiful welcome to
legend of zelda ocarina of time just
like we remembered it
ah just sleeping in my bed good times
oh great not not only in the link we'll
have nightmares this is great
wake up in the morning hashtag relatable
link hahaha all right the great Deku
Tree one says well I better get on my
way then
and we're off what the actual [ __ ] is
happening ah damn it
hey why ride the horse when you can fly
that horse so this is what drugs
underwater sounds like oh I think I
entered my name tell em I do oh my god
bad face oh god I'm scared I'm really
scared
hey how's everyone doing hey they live
with them
don't mind me those are my boots yes
just tickling my ass don't worry about
it
that is so [ __ ] creepy look at that
face well I'll be I'll be on my way now
excuse me huh just gotta go and save
Hyrule don't mind me love swimming
everyone loves a good swim don't they
okay then hi we found the Sun yeah great
so happy happy happy
hey how's everyone doing that's great
I'll be on my way now
thanks this is not how I remembered it
not at all Oh can't tell me what to do
adventurer oh don't mind me it's
chilling down here with my hand through
my face balloon link my favorite type of
link am i shorter I think either that or
I really have to take a [ __ ] oh gosh
it's so creepy
[ __ ] yeah oh my god link where is your
face are okay Oh
oh that's some kinky [ __ ] link haha
if now I walk up in the club baby sorry
party nice boobs you got there link
great food [ __ ] crab link walks like
crabs talk like wait white breakdancing
link my favorite link hey where you
going buddy I came in like link ball all
I wanted was Jesus Christ I want to see
links to face our God this is creepy
ah Jesus show me your face link why
don't you show me your beautiful face
link man Oh fighter of the demons man oh
oh god his face his [ __ ] face shake I
did you down
ah alright yeah no you know that's
enough nightmares for today thank you
very much thank you very very much like
video watching in disguise number today
I used to vine sauce rom crafter a
linked info for it in the description as
always thank you for watching and stay
awesome